solo with Star Wars story might not be
the same kind of box-office Bonanza that
Disney has gotten used to since adding
Lucasfilm to it's menagerie of studios
but the film has still given fans a lot
to talk about
centered on the title space pirate as he
makes his way from the mean streets of
Corellia to his fabled Kessel run solo
gives the hesitant hero some new
cinematic life with Alden Ehrenreich
stepping into Harrison Ford's old boots
his journey fills in a lot of blanks
about Han Solo's past up to and
including the origin of his name and in
the process turns out quite a few
references that were quite clearly meant
to ring familiar even to the most casual
fans in a galaxy far far away familiar
parlance it wouldn't be a han Solo movie
without some of his choice catchphrases
coming into play
the easiest nods to the characters
previous pieces of dialogue were direct
like when Han is referred to as a flyboy
by his new cohorts on Tobias Beckett's
team and when he calls his budding
sidekick Chewbacca move milker for what
is probably the first time of many at
other points the approach was to turn an
iconic phrase on its head instead of the
classic I have a bad feeling about this
line that makes its way into every Star
Wars movie Hans delight at taking the
wheel inspires the happier version I
have a really good feeling about this
and when Lando Calrissian has decidedly
had enough of the KO axiom heist and all
the damage it's doing to his precious
Millennium Falcon and he tells Han I
hate you at which point Han replies I
know it's a nod to the signature
exchange he'll later have with Leia
Organa and is clearly meant to show the
strong effect Hans had on people since
the beginning too tough to tangle with
solo also takes place before rogue 1 a
Star Wars story and the film overtly
tells us as much by including SCARA
among the many familiar planet names
that are dropped by characters
throughout while there are plenty of
other familiar locales that should make
star wars aficionados ears perk the
mention of scar F is about much more
than letting us know it's still intact
in the timeline of solo it also
reaffirms just how gutsy the events of
rogue 1 really were the planet is
mentioned by Kira as a possible source
of some replacement Co axiom after the
team muffs their first attempt to boost
some from a train on Vandor one scarf is
quickly passed over because of the heavy
security surrounding the planet and the
group instead opts to risk the Kessel
run with unstable explosives rather than
even take a chance at scar F in other
words jyn erso and her little band of
rebels were even braver than we knew
the seeds of rebellion the first
stand-alone Star Wars story rogue one
was basically a feature-length tribute
to some of the previously unknown heroes
that help feel the rebellion that would
ultimately topple an empire by getting
those Death Star plans into Leia's hands
solo on the other hand is focused on the
history and character development of the
galaxy's most lovable rogue and proves
he was known to act unselfishly on at
least one occasion prior to saving Luke
Skywalker from Darth Vader squadron of
TIE fighters what it means for Han to
betray dryden vos and deliver the
precious fuel to emphasis ragtag team is
fairly epic before he was ready to align
with anyone who'd fill his pockets but
now he has scruples and guts and fists
nest else on that the co axiom is the
blood of a new rebellion in other words
long before Han would ever meet Luke and
obi-wan at the cantina he'd already
begun his work aiding the Rebel Alliance
let the wookie win some references are a
little more obscure than others like
when Lando Calrissian uses his downtime
to chronicle his adventures via hologram
and makes mention of the alien race the
shahru this is a major nod to the novel
Lando Calrissian and the mind harp of
charu which hasn't been considered canon
but offers its own sort of pre-war
adventure tale of Lando and a droid
going on a treasure hunt the book and
its sequels might not have gotten much
on-screen love in the past but the scene
seems to finally give weight to those
crazy adventure stories similarly Solo
also gives a nod to artist Phil Tippett
and John Berg's missing hollow chest
characters bulbous and scrimp which were
omitted from the de jerec boards shown
in a new hope in the force awakens but
were kept by the artists as souvenirs of
their Star Wars adventures in a solo
scene aboard the Millennium Falcon
Chewbacca is shown learning the game
with Beckett and attempting to wipe the
pieces away in a moment of typical
frustration permanently damaging the
board in his fit of rage and causing the
two pieces to blink out of existence who
shoots first
perhaps no Star Wars issue has been so
furiously debated as whether or not Han
Solo shot first in his fateful showdown
with Greedo Solo doesn't answer that
specific question precisely but it does
pay respects to the issue with a much
more conclusive version of some similar
events in the film's final scenes han
confronts Beckett on the beach after his
pseudo mentor betrays him and it becomes
clear their differences can't be
resolved peacefully using his signature
blaster pistol given to him by Beckett
han decides to act first and whips out
his weapon to put one into Beckett's
chess before Beckett can
ever draw his own sidearm scum and
villainy yuen-han is driven by two
central desires rescuing his gal pal
Kira and earning his wings as a bonafide
pilot by the time we meet him in a new
hope however he's become a wayward
employee of Jabba the Hutt driven mostly
by his greed and the bounty on his head
solo teases that future even after
painting Han is the good guy for his
contribution to emphasis burgeoning
rebellion by telling us what his next
move will be Becket mentions a rumor
that a big shot gangster is putting
together a crew on Tatooine and Han
decides to follow that lead that big
shot gangster can only be Jabba the Hutt
that's where Hans headed for better or
worse thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]